- Today, we're talking about Maritime Law,
which is why I'm standing next
to my yacht, the Legal Seagull.
Wait, where did it go?
Damn you, pirates.
(trumpet sounds)
Ahoy, legal eagles, today,
we're talking about pirates,
specifically sea pirates
and the Law of the Sea,
because believe it or not,
pirates actually had a huge effect on,
not only the founding of our country,
but also the way that our laws
were shaped both domestically
and internationally.
So let's talk about what
it means to be a pirate
and why that's incredibly illegal.
So first we need to talk about
what laws govern the ocean.
And there's actually three
overlapping types of law.
First there's Maritime Law,
which is generally the law
related to private ships
and commercial shipping.
And then there's Admiralty Law,
which generally relates
to the law of shipping,
whether it's navigable waters in rivers
or on the ocean itself.
And then there's the Law of the Sea,
which is an actual thing,
that is the international law related
to the use of oceans and seas.
So Maritime and Admiralty
Law tends to be domestic,
while the Law of the Sea tends
to be the international rules
amongst different nations.
Now, shipping was incredibly important
to the United States
when it was a new nation.
And that's why it's
mentioned several times
in the US Constitution.
Article three defines the boundaries
of subject matter
jurisdiction for the courts.
Specifically, it extends
to the judicial power
of the United States to
quote "all Cases of Admiralty
and maritime Jurisdiction."
And if you're a US lawyer
dealing with Maritime Law,
you're probably dealing
with laws like the Merchant
Marine Act of 1928,
also known as the Jones Act.
This act gives sailors the right
to sue negligent sea
captains and companies,
if they're injured on the seas.
And it also highly
restricts the type of ships
that are allowed to transport
goods in the United States.
Specifically, the Jones
Act says that any ship
that transports goods between
two different US states has
to be built in the United States,
be owned 75% by US citizens,
be crewed at least 75% by US
citizens and fly a US flag.
Now you're probably thinking who cares.
This is just an esoteric law about ships,
but it actually has a huge
impact on the US economy.
And for you, my fellow US consumer,
can make things incredibly expensive.
For example, the cost of
shipping one container
from Los Angeles to
Shanghai is about $900.
Whereas the cost of
shipping that same container
from Los Angeles to
Hawaii is about $10,000.
And as a result, states
like Alaska and Hawaii
and territories like Puerto Rico
have incredibly high shipping
rates just to get things
from one state to another.
Whereas those rates often don't
apply to foreign countries.
And while you might be thinking, Hey,
it's good for American
shipbuilders and American sailors.
Well, there aren't actually that many.
US shipbuilding basically
doesn't exist anymore,
outside of the defense industry,
there are less than a hundred ships
that meet the requirements
of the Jones Act.
So in times of emergency,
sometimes these states are
just completely screwed.
This might be the
dumbest law on the books.
It's enough to drive you to piracy,
which is what we're
going to talk about next.
So it might not surprise you to learn
that if you commit the act
of piracy on the high seas,
you can be prosecuted as such
and during the golden age of piracy,
there were thousands and
thousands of pirates operating
in the Caribbean and
off the Barbary Coast,
which had a huge effect on
the formation of this nation.
In the Caribbean, they boarded
merchant ships from Britain,
the Netherlands, France and Portugal,
and played big powers against each other.
Some of their exploits are legendary.
Blackbeard captured a former
slave ship named the Concorde,
renamed it Queen Anne's Revenge
and blockaded Charleston Harbor in 1718.
Piracy was such a menace
that it made its way
into the constitution.
Article one, section eight, clause 10,
gives Congress the power to quote,
"define and punish piracy and felonies
on the high seas and offenses
against the law of nations."
And in 1790 Congress
used that authorization
to create the first anti-piracy act.
And this had nothing to do with software,
it was about actual sea pirates.
The statute defined piracy
as murder or robbery
on the high seas or any
other crime committed
on the high seas that would be punishable
by death under US law,
if committed on land.
The Supreme Court held that
the 1790 statute was limited
in its scope and American
courts couldn't penalize people
who committed piracy,
if they weren't American citizens sailing
on a US flag vessel,
or if they didn't inflict
actual harm on US citizens.
Congress eventually
amended the law in 1819,
specifying that piracy
didn't need a specific nexus
to the United States.
That's actually very rare in law
because if you have watched
this channel before, you know
that standing is an incredibly
important requirement
for almost any US lawsuit or prosecution.
However, rather than
defining what piracy meant,
as it did in the original statute,
it referred to the crime
of piracy as defined
by the law of nations.
The punishment for piracy
under the 1890 law was death.
In 1909, the penalty was
changed to life imprisonment
and the 1909 law hasn't been
amended since its passage.
And it's found at 18 USC 1651,
but the first challenge of
the 1819 law came swiftly
in 1820.
When a man named Smith
participated in a mutiny
on a private vessel
commissioned by the colony
of Buenos Aires.
Smith and his mates
imprisoned the captain,
seized another pirate ship
called the Irresistible,
and robbed a Spanish vessel.
Smith was convicted to piracy,
but he took his conviction
to the Supreme Court.
Smith argued that the definition
of piracy was too vague,
but the court disagreed.
The Supreme Court held
that piracy was defined
with reasonable certainty
by the law of nations
and that robbery on the high
seas was a component of piracy.
The nations hate piracy,
and they hate pirates,
which is why they want
to prosecute pirates
whenever they can.
So the US and many other
developed countries have taken
a universal approach to this kind of law.
This kind of international
law is actually very rare,
but it did serve as a
template for the prosecutions
in Nuremberg and Tokyo
following World War II.
Now it took 200 years for the
US to prosecute another case
of piracy, but in 2010,
the US actually prosecuted
two different cases of piracy.
The first US versus Said involved pirates,
who shot at the USS Ashland,
the pirates boarded a small
skiff and fired weapons
at the Ashland, but
didn't attempt to board.
The pirates moved to dismiss the case,
since they didn't board or
take control of the USS Ashland
and the US District
Court granted the motion.
The court said
that the piracy statute
only allowed prosecutions
for quote "robbery or forcible
depredations upon the sea."
The definition given to piracy
by the United States
Supreme Court in Smith,
190 years earlier.
But in the sister case
in US versus Hassan,
the Fourth Circuit expanded
the definition of piracy
beyond just robbery.
In that case, Somali pirates,
mistakenly thought a US military vessel,
the USS Nicholas was
actually a merchant ship.
The pirates opened fire on the ship
and the USS Nicholas crew fired back.
The pirates agreed to flee,
but they were captured
and brought to the US,
where they became the first
men convicted of piracy
in 200 years.
They were given life sentences.
However, the men thought
that they could appeal based
on the Said case.
They had not boarded the USS Nicholas,
nor did they rob the vessel.
Unfortunately for them,
the Fourth Circuit expanded
the definition of robbery
and upheld the convictions.
The court held that when
Congress enacted 18 USC 1651,
and provided for piracy to be
defined by the law of nations,
Congress knew that the
definition of piracy would expand
and evolve as the law of nations evolved.
The court noted that the
international definition
of piracy has included many actions
beyond robbery and murder.
The Fourth Circuit held
that limiting the definition
of piracy to robbery on
the high seas would quote,
"render it incongruous with
the modern law of nations
and prevent the federal courts
from exercising universal
jurisdiction in piracy cases."
The Fourth Circuit reversed the dismissal
of the piracy count in Said.
The bottom line is that
under modern US law,
piracy on the high seas
involves things other
than just robbery.
So pirates, be prepared to walk the plank.
And at this point we're pretty
good at prosecuting pirates.
America kicking pirates' ass
since 1801, with I guess,
a few exceptions to that rule.
Unfortunately, we've
replaced pirates with trash.
The oceans are absolutely
clogged with trash,
which is why it's time that
we all did something about it.
Which is why I joined TeamSeas,
a group of YouTube creators who are trying
to raise $30 million to remove
30 million pounds of trash
from the ocean.
Now, this is normally
the part of the video
where I would talk about
Curiosity Stream and Nebula,
but this is more important.
And that's why Curiosity Stream decided
to donate their sponsor
time to allow me to tell you
about TeamSeas.
It couldn't be more simple.
There's a link on screen and
below this video right now,
that will take you to the
donation button for TeamSeas.
And if you could donate,
I'd really appreciate it.
100% of the proceeds go to our partners,
the Ocean Conservancy,
and the Ocean Cleanup.
And it couldn't be easier.
The link below we'll take
you to the donation page
for TeamSeas and no amount is too small.
$1 means one less pound of trash
that makes it into the ocean.
$5 means five pounds of trash and plastic
that won't be in the ocean.
Together, we can rid the ocean of plastic
and trash the same way
that we rid the ocean
of those dirty pirates.
Now, if you'll, excuse me,
I'm going to go find my boat.
(piano music ends)